the man who kicks things off every
single day on pro football talk live pro
football talks mike florio here to kick
off hour number two how are you michael
doing great rich how are you i am doing
well what's going on in jacksonville
best you can tell right now
we're talking i i think that the report
that we saw on saturday from nfl media
isn't
the
cause as much as it's the symptom of
what's been going on there are multiple
people in the building that just don't
care for urban meyer they don't like the
way he treats people and they have been
peddling stories and details and
anecdotes for weeks now it all goes back
to when he didn't accompany the team
back to jacksonville after they lost
that thursday night game in cincinnati
and regardless of whatever photos made
the rounds the key is he abandoned his
post he didn't fly with his team
back to jacksonville and that emboldened
people to begin to talk and they've been
talking and talking and it finally
reached critical mass on saturday and
that's really the biggest issue that
they're dealing with right now and i
know he suggested yesterday whoever the
source is will be unemployed first of
all he's not going to find out who the
source is second of all it's not just
one person there are multiple people
that are talking to the media they're
motivated to do so because they don't
like him and what the owner has to
decide is how long is he going to
continue this is he going to double down
the dysfunctional teams tend to double
down when they make mistakes the good
teams
either don't make mistakes at all or
when they make a mistake they spot it
they rectify it and they move on but the
indications are that meyer is going to
be back i just i'm going to be
fascinated rich to see what his coaching
staff looks like
next year because he hired these people
they not all of them but enough of them
because there's always stuff that goes
on in a locker room on a practice field
in a meeting room and depending upon
what the perspective of the observer is
it can be a big deal or not we don't
hear about that stuff you only hear
about that stuff when people don't like
the guy who's in charge that's the
fundamental issue that the jaguars need
to wrestle with
there are too many people who don't like
the guy in charge what are they going to
do about that going forward well it's
also the players too right because you
can't you know
look we were we're all wondering uh in
in the media is how urban was going to
handle losing you know
and and how is he going to handle losses
racking up that eclipse number of losses
that he would suffer over a span of
years or a tenure right there's 11
losses for jacksonville right now two
more than he had in his entire tenure at
ohio state you could tell
the answer to that question is not well
not not handling it well at all or he
handles it in the same way that he would
handle one loss in a season and the
problem is is that that that would be an
outlier
now it's a weekly occurrence and that
wears on people
so you know the players though you can't
fire those all of them and those are the
ones that are according to tom pelicero
were talking to rams players at the end
of that loss here in los angeles and
that's how stuff gets out too oh
absolutely and i agree with you
completely the idea that losing a game
or two now at the nfl level it's not as
magnified as it is at the college level
i think that's how he kind of justified
rolling the dice with not a great team
because hey you lose seven or eight
games you're still in the playoff hunt
in the nfl well you lose 11 and you're
done as the jaguars now are but that's
part of what he has to deal with and you
can internalize it or you can
externalize it and it sounds like he's
spent a lot of this year
instead of holding it in
taking it out on anyone who happens to
be around because it's not his fault
it's never his fault nothing's ever his
fault so it must be someone else's fault
and he's by all appearances done what he
can to put the blame on anyone that he
can find to blame except himself
so you know and one thing that he said
he's not used to um i mean talking about
you know i guess leaks and people
talking
uh about him like they talked about him
um is playing out the string which is
what jacksonville's doing now so what
what what happens over the next four
weeks in your estimation crystal ball
with with any knowledge you may have
about how expensive a move it would be
to move on well no one knows what he's
making we reported back when he was
in the market for an nfl job he was
looking for 12 million and there was an
angry reaction to that which means he
wasn't getting anywhere close to 12
million the best number i can piece
together is six and a half per year plus
some form of incentive package possibly
and that's a lot lower than what we
thought an urban meyer would make when
he makes the jump to the nfl so i don't
know what the total buyout would be how
much is guaranteed how many years go out
there but it's a big check if you want
to move on the question becomes what
will shot khan do about this and
the jaguars have a unique
structure as it relates to pr for
certain things when you ask the team for
comment they send you to the owner's
spokesperson a guy named jim woodcock
and
so
when this comes out hey jaguars what's
your comment on these reports that these
things happen they send you to the
spokesman for the owner and he says no
comment and i went back and forth with
him yesterday and he eventually sent me
an article recently that was published
in the florida times union where sean
khan
has a bunch of different comments and he
talks about failure and dealing with
failure and how he's dealt with failure
in the private sector and how it's
different in sports because everything's
magnified but you get the impression
that he's not going to just cave in he's
not going to give and i mean he's got
the lowest winning percentage of any
owner who's had a team for the amount of
time that he's had the team 10 years now
and the total number of games
no one has been
more unsuccessful than him so i guess
he's kind of used to it
and i think he is going to be inclined
to double down but you know all it takes
is one moment all it takes is one thing
you never know what that straw is going
to be that breaks the camel's back and
remember this
this year
the window opens two weeks early on
potentially moving on from coaches and
interviewing
guys who are working for other teams
that's something that the league put
through in october and that could cause
some teams to start firing coaches two
weeks before we're accustomed to the
coaches being fired so the window opens
not in four weeks from today it opens
basically two weeks from today how about
that mike florio here on the rich eisen
show what's the uh what's the status of
matt nagy you think in chicago four and
nine right now justin field shows
flashes when he's not hurt uh behind
that porous offensive line that's
obviously naggy's fault but what do you
what do you make of his status in
chicago right now from one dysfunctional
organization to another and
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things so
it's always hard to predict what a
dysfunctional team is going to do right
when they trade up
from number 20 to number 11 give up next
year's first round pick to to get justin
field i look at that and i say okay
somebody in that organization has
decided
that they're going to stick with matt
nagy for a couple of years if they're
going to stick with ryan pace the gm for
a couple of years and give this kid a
chance to develop that you're not going
to put everyone under a win now mandate
when you've gone all in for a
quarterback that's going to take some
time to get to his highest level of
achievement because if you get a new
coach there's no guarantee the new coach
wants that quarterback he may say it
during the interview process and he may
convince you that he believes it but
once he's there and he's got his
guaranteed contract well all of a sudden
yeah maybe this guy or maybe that guy or
maybe this guy doesn't really fit with
the offense i want to run so
i i thought that when they made the
trade rich it meant naggy and pace got
two more years and now obviously the
storm clouds are building and there was
a report from cbs on sunday that they've
spoken to trace armstrong who was a
first round pick of the bears in 89 and
spent 16 years in the nfl he's in the
100 sack club he's a successful agent
now primarily for coaches
that they've talked to him about taking
over the football operations he denied
it
brian day the i state coach was linked
to
armstrong but the one thing that was
overlooked in all this he represents
nagi
so so
it's just one big stinking mess and i
mentioned that possibility of someone in
charge of football operations because if
they do start firing people this time
around rich they need to go one level
higher and target ted phillips he's got
one of these gigs that most teams have a
person like this
who is part of the football operation
but when the pooh hits the fan pardon me
they're not and they go run for cover
and they don't get fired so 20 years
later and a bunch of bad hires later
that person's still calling the shots it
could be that this time
it goes up one level higher and they
clear out everybody and start over again
i guess i was thinking when i heard ryan
day's name mentioned that uh whoever
loses the michigan ohio state game was
apparently rumored to be the next bears
coach year in and year out you know
so i wonder if they i wonder if they're
leaking ryan day to get jim harbaugh to
be in
i don't know about that i mean the
ultimate born on third i think you hit a
triple move
and then harbaugh says no sorry ryan day
i'll take that job so what what about uh
ryan day what could he be like
jacksonville too because you know uh uh
that that's a possibility i mean wha wha
what what uh college coaches could
potentially be on
radar screens in the nfl well right now
the owners
are
are very much influenced by recent
history they say that the nfl is a
copycat league i i think that it's more
like the owners don't know what to do so
they look at whatever's successful right
now and they say well i'll do the same
thing so you look at what's happening
with urban meyer in jacksonville and the
guy who succeeded him in ohio state
would you touch that guy right now if
you were an owner of a team i mean i
think of the ridicule you're going to
get oh well we took you know we took the
guy that urban meyer handed a successful
program to and he's still mostly
successful and we expect that guy to be
better than urban meyer when you know he
worked with meyer and look at what a
mess it is for meyer i think it's going
to be hard to sell ryan day
until meyer either becomes successful or
some other college coach who jumps to
the nfl becomes successful you know matt
rule started off 3-0 and now i think
he's in trouble he's just being replaced
do you think so
well
because david tepper the owner of that
team is determined to get the best
of everything as it relates to coach gm
and quarterback
the amazon series that they don't
produce anymore it was called all or
nothing the year that they had the
panthers is the focal point the very
last episode david tepper is riding in
the backseat of an suv and he says the
nfl is set up for all teams to be 500
and where you go above that or below
that is up to you and if you want to be
above that you have to have a great
coach a great gm and a great quarterback
and i think tepper
has
a very short fuse when it comes to
up or down is this guy great or not
great teddy bridgewater one year not
great gone sam darnold half a season not
great gone
and has he seen enough from matt rule in
two years look something happened that
is unusual to say the least to result in
joe brady the offensive coordinator
being fired at 15 after one o'clock
eastern on the sunday of their bye week
six days after the normal time you fire
somebody when you're changing offenses
or changing play callers during your bye
week so
there's definitely a vibe that david
tepper may have seen enough from matt
rule and he's going to move on and try
to find you know he wants vince lombardi
george young and tom brady and he's not
going to rest until he has all three so
who else might be uh on that hot seat
guys it's interesting you point out
again that the window to start
interviewing candidates is two weeks
earlier than usual so
what do you think well i think mike
zimmer in minnesota
is a guy who's in
danger to say the least where they are
right now it's just the same old thing
they're treading water they're dog
paddling they've blown so many leads
this year and even though they
ultimately won the game on thursday
night that's one of those games where in
the owner's box to the extent that they
are allowed to smoke cigars in there and
i assume they're not that's where you
want to light one up midway through the
third quarter and just enjoy the rest of
the game well the next thing you know
here well there's one oh there's another
oh there's another before you know it
you're in another game that goes down to
the last freaking play up 29 to nothing
and it's yet another vikings game that
has to come down to the last play and
but for chase claypool in the ridiculous
celebration of a first down catch that
took 14 seconds off the clock before
they could snap it the steelers would
have had another shot or two at the end
zone so i think zimmer
has to get to the round of eight and i
don't think he will to come back next
year i think at this point just getting
the seventh seed and getting knocked out
by the second seed is not going to be
nearly good enough and and because it's
just you know playoffs one year no
playoffs in next year and there's no
real sign of growth no sign of progress
and no sign that he's fully in charge of
the team he's in charge of the defense
and he throws the keys to the offense
the offensive coordinator that's just
not good enough mike florio pro football
talk few more that's left with him right
here on the rich eisen show so um the
the scenario in the afc they're the
patriots now two in front of the bills
um who had their uh star quarterback in
a just starring role what a remarkable
comeback that josh allen led but it led
him to be in a walk-in boot to leave and
then the ravens lose to the browns who
have an opportunity now win this
division
um having split with the browns they've
already won one with the bengals who
have swept the steelers and have already
beaten the ravens once and they could
wind up sweeping the ravens too
certainly if lamar jackson has some
considerable time out what do you know
about the injury status of both of those
quarterbacks right now on this monday
well josh allen downplayed his injury
but
the boot isn't a fashion statement rich
right he's got it on for a reason and
kyle murray downplayed his sprained
ankle that he suffered in the next last
play of the week eight game against the
packers and we didn't see him for five
more weeks
so i never trust what comes out of the
quarterback's mouth or any player's
mouth right after they're injured
because there's a certain amount of
hard-headedness and wishful thinking
that goes into it so turf toe is what
i've seen left foot turf toe that's not
good and
yeah they unleashed him yesterday unlike
they have in a long time
i think after his rookie season when he
had a couple of
100 yard rushing games they decided to
be more careful with him until like huge
games key moments post season apparently
they decided yesterday this is the
moment this is the time to switch back
to southpaw and go after you know a
better offensive showing than what
they've had i think brian dabal is in
serious trouble there as well with the
offense he's been running but with allen
it's too early to know and with lamar
john harbaugh said after the game it is
a sprain and they're going to do tests
today and there's been some different
opinions is it low ankle is it is it
high ankle whatever they're going to
defer to the test and figure out exactly
what it is almost like last week with
marlon humphrey there was reporting it
was his shoulder it ended up being a
torn pec you have to in some of these
just wait and see what the diagnostic
evaluation is and then you know exactly
what it is and how long he may be out
but you know the ravens just been
holding it together like one injury
after another all the way back to
training camp it's amazing they're even
in it at this point and if they'd lose a
lamar it would be even harder for them
to to hold on yeah
where are the long-term contracts for
the starting quarterbacks in the game
yesterday well i mean lamar should have
his the problem is lamar represents
himself
and lamar there was a story
from shefty i think week one lamar's too
focused on football to negotiate the
controversy it's all the more reason to
hire an agent i mean whatever you save
in that two percent one percent whatever
it is you can negotiate it as low as you
want there's agents out there willing to
do it for one percent whatever you save
you're going to make
over that
by orders of magnitude especially if you
end up getting yourself injured and you
never get that big contract
offered to you by your team so he should
have had his deal a long time ago his
issue isn't the team's unwillingness to
do it it's that he isn't engaged in the
process with the ravens and they're just
kind of waiting for him for the browns
and baker mayfield different story
altogether they just aren't talking
because i don't think they know
whether or not he's the guy
really
that's it huh i mean it's just
because
there or or they just don't want the
number to start with a four annually
right i mean
it's going to be together it's like hey
we'll keep you around for 30 million a
year but we won't keep you for 40
million or you know what if we're going
to pay 30 million
we'll just roll the dice on somebody
else this gets back to what we talked
about earlier when do you admit your
mistake when do you admit that it's not
right when do you recognize we just have
to forget what we've done and focus on
what we're going to do mary kay cabot of
cleveland plain dealer
had an article that that tried to
discern what baker was talking about
when he went public with kurt warner
over the weekend and said that there are
a lot of internal things that have been
an issue this year that you usually
don't hear that from a quarterback and
they're
by all appearances there's a lot of
stuff between mayfield and the team and
it's happening with the contract
uncertainty in the background i i just
don't think
it ends well and
i think the browns need to acknowledge
it and mayfield needs to acknowledge it
i don't who would anyone give mayfield
something right now that starts with a
four no no no no i i n nor would i but i
would definitely sign him long term i
mean like at some point mike we're going
to see a team do one of two things
uh in this situation we're gonna see a
team um
tell this quarterback yeah you were
drafted first overall and you're our guy
but we are not gonna pay you top dollar
just because you were drafted first
overall all those years ago certainly by
somebody that wasn't me
you know so we're gonna find a a
contract in the sweet middle you know in
the sweet middle of like of jimmy
garoppolo or a little hair above what
jimmy garoppolo got right like that's
what we're gonna do
or we'll do the other thing that we're
still waiting for team to do which is
we're going to draft somebody first
overall we're going to go through that
guy's contract and then we're going to
start again and we'll just do it again
because we're not going to get caps
strung and we're going to try and win a
super bowl with a new guy in his first
year years of his contract which is the
sweet stuff that the chiefs were able to
do and the seahawks were able to do back
in the day and very few other teams have
been able to do like that's what we're
going to see and maybe the browns are
they hey rich your your lips to the
football god's ears back in june of 2019
i was shouting as loud as i could to the
rams do not sign
jared goff to a second contract don't do
it just because he's got three years in
and he took it to a super bowl and he's
eligible for a new deal don't do it
don't do it and they were acting like i
was crazy fred rogan had sean mcveigh on
his radio show and they were like oh
that's just ridiculous oh he's never
going to not be here all of the bs that
we hear all the time when we're really
sold heavy bs and fine look what you get
you pay him 33.5 million you eventually
have to offload the deal two years later
as part of a broader trade where you
kind of you hide goff's contract in
there and give up a first round pick to
get rid of goff's contract but it's not
as conspicuous as it would be because
it's part of the broader matthew
stafford transaction that's exactly what
some of these teams need to do and it's
either see you later or rich it's the
creation of a second tier you know for a
while it was the next guy who was do a
contract who is on the pass side of pass
fail automatically becomes the highest
paid player in league history and it
went andrew luck derek carr jimmy
garoppolo kirk cousins matthew stafford
matt ryan one after another that doesn't
work anymore
hey yeah we'd like to keep you but
you're not getting 40 million a year
we'll keep you at 30 million a year and
uh otherwise see you later that's what
somebody needs to do and maybe the
browns will be the ones who do it with
mayfield
last one for you mike in a couple
minutes i have left here what can you
tell me about the raiders
what's their
last few weeks gonna be here best you
can tell what are you hearing about them
the last reporting i saw about mark
davis and his plans for looking for a
new coach is he hadn't started yet
because he's focused on the postseason
well he's about at the point where he
can forget focusing on the postseason
and he's two weeks away from being able
to start interviewing
other
coaches from other teams but it's
clearly not going to be rich versace
long term he wouldn't have that job he
wouldn't have even been interviewed for
the job he was just at the right place
at the worst possible time for john
gruden and on john gruden
by my calculation unless there's been an
extension informally agreed to by the
lawyers
that
response from the nfl and roger goodell
to the john gruden lawsuit could be
landing as soon as today it'll be very
interesting to see what their next move
is on this this broader litigation chess
board it's been a while but you get a
month or so and and i think today may be
the day i was going to ask you what's
going on with gruden what are you
hearing about john about any of that
stuff well just it's you know it's once
it gets into the the gears of formal
litigation there's a lot of delays that
are baked into it especially early on
but but we're getting there and we'll
see now i guess there's also a chance
that they may have quietly settled it
but that would that would defy the
rhetoric that we saw from the league but
maybe they learned their lesson with st
louis and they've decided cash out of
these things sooner rather than later
mike thanks for the time greatly
appreciate it always appreciated thank
you sir thanks rich good talking to you
bet that's mike florio check him out
every single day
on nbc sports on peacock to kick things
off before the dan patrick show and then
comes ours and then brother from another
that's how we roll every single day here
on nbc sports on peacock hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here